Some kind of virgin,
because it's only this year that I need to preserve my mouth,
I'm going to pull off the wrath of God, and I'm going to gather at Sakama.
I will buy the wrath of God Tatemachi
4 who gave birth to the best child in the world 4 It's
India 96
That's amazing, even if you lose your virginity for the first time at the age of 96, the
fact that you can preserve your species means that you can kill the 97-year-old and above.
Is it a mission from God?
Can you identify me?  Hey everyone, it's
okay I'm a
public boy and I'm a deco girl
Shizu-goh
That's a Freemasonry conspiracy Hey, let's wear these clothes and go to
Harajuku Because my brother can be a virgin So
what a Max
everyone, a virgin was killed in Harajuku  I've never seen the news
, but they're putting pressure on the mass media.
But if you wear this kind of clothes, you'll be killed in one shot I think you can make clothes with boobs Kasumi-san, you seem to have some sort of
survival ability or something like
that.  No, your heart is steamed and for some
reason, you're in the same room with your heart.
Detan
Weapon can be a knife
[music]
What are you talking about